Donald Trump's campaign is starting a
new line of attack with 13 days to go
Trump is trying to link Hillary Clinton
to President Obama's health care law his
campaign jumped on the news that many
Obama care premiums will rise by double
digits next year Donald Trump used his
new ammunition at the end of a campaign
swing in Florida a crucial state for him
to win this morning he's taking time out
to open his new hotel that's just a few
blocks from the White House major
Garrett is outside the Trump
International Hotel in Washington major
good morning good morning at the stage
of the campaign time is the most
precious commodity oddly Donald Trump
will not spend this morning in a
battleground state but here in the
District of Columbia where Democrats
typically rack up ninety percent of the
presidential vote it will be his second
marketing event in as many days raising
questions in some Republican circles is
Trump more interested in self-promotion
than victory his age insist he wants to
win and he will relentlessly exploit
Obamacare woes as this campaign winds
down job-killing Obamacare is just one
more way that our system is rigged
believe me in Tallahassee Donald Trump
said an average premium increase of 25%
disguises the real damage of Obamacare
they know that's not true it's much more
you're gonna have sixty seventy eighty
ninety percent three states will see
premium increases over sixty percent
with changes ranging from a 145 percent
spike in Phoenix to a four percent
decrease in Indianapolis adjusted
taxpayer-funded subsidies will help
reduce some sticker shock we get rid of
Obamacare and we come up with a plan
that's so much less expensive Trump
offered no alternative to the law but
traveled to his Doral Golf Club to say
this about its effect on his staff all
of my employees are having a tremendous
problem with Obamacare the club's
general manager quickly corrected Trump
telling reporters more than ninety five
percent of the staff is insured by the
hotel maybe there's a few that aren't
sure through Obamacare but very very few
Tuesday night try
clarified it's a small group but it's a
group that's having tremendous problems
and as much as Trump tried to stay on
message he could not resist Vice
President Joe Biden's recent taunt the
press always asked me don't I wish I
were debating him no I wish her in high
school I could take him behind the gym
that's what I wish did you see where
Biden wants to take me to the back of
the barn me he wants I'd love that I'd
love that mr. tough guy after the
ribbon-cutting here Donald Trump will
have a fundraising luncheon with a bunch
of Republicans trying to raise money as
Democrats pour money into the campaign
to try to win back control the United
States Senate and heat into house
Republican majorities then Trump leaves
for another battleground state north
carolina right behind florida in his
must have electoral vote strategy he'll
major thank you